[Music]
good morning Hank it's Friday March 9th
my eyes still kind of funny Hank on
Wednesday afternoon for some reason I
went out and I bought a lot of peeps and
I decided to eat them as fast as I could
at the time I didn't know that we would
be introduced to Kurt the punk-rock
nerdfighter so I thought that I would
prove how awesome I was by eating peeps
faster than you I mean not that
everything's a contest between us and
not that I feel compelled to win each
one of those contests so I gave myself
three minutes to eat as many peeps as
possible I would like to show you the
results from that experiment I got a
whole stack of piece Hank I may not like
the taste of peeps but I sure do like
the taste of sugar so in the beginning I
found it very easy to eat the peeps as
you can see they're going in one right
after another after all I've been on
Weight Watchers for eight weeks this
felt very good it's only ten points for
15 peeps and then as you can see I began
to slow down a little the Ghostbusters
and the Stay Puft Marshmallow Man had
begun to war inside me soon the peeps
began to hurt they began to expand
inside my stomach growing like so many
slowly inflating balloons I felt a
renewed sense of enthusiasm upon
switching to the pink peeps
I thought maybe by switching to the pink
peeps I would be able to eat peeps
quickly and efficiently proving myself
to be the greatest peeps eater in the
history of the green family but my
enthusiasm was short-lived Hank in the
world of competitive eating there is a
phrase the wall of fat the wall of fact
is the wall that your stomach hits when
it's trying to expand and then it runs
up against your subcutaneous fat thin
eaters like Takeru Kobayashi the
greatest competitive eater in history
don't have to worry about the wall of
fat but I'm not thin yet Hank I'm still
a heavyweight according to the
International Boxing Federation so I
began to hit the wall of fat at this
point all of the peeps I could eat were
inside my mouth but there was the small
matter of getting them from my mouth in
my belly and as you can see that process
took quite a long time there was so much
chewing to do every time I thought I had
swallowed the end of the peeps there was
more peeps to eat do you see that Hank
that is exactly what peeps puke looks
like how do I know wait
at this point I think I can maybe still
hold down the peeps I think I can hold
down the peeps and I think I can oh no
I'm not gonna hold down the peeps hank
be grateful that I didn't take the video
camera into the bathroom with me I had
what is known in competitive eating
circles as a reversal of fortune Hank in
the end a 12 and a half peeps in three
minutes you ate 12 and a half peeps in 6
minutes
Kirt ate 12 peeps in a minute-and-a-half
scientific conclusion it's not possible
to eat more than twelve and a half peeps
in a single sitting
I'll see you on Monday there is now a
link at brotherhood to calm that allows
you to contribute to the brotherhood 2.0
fund for decreasing suck levels
worldwide so please contribute and help
us do something about suck